to Lebanese MPS are beginning week two
of a sitting inside Parliament they're
promising to stay put until a new
president's elected after months of
political paralysis we're going to get
more on this from zaynakoda in Beirut
Xena this must be very frustrating for
the people in Lebanese tell us what's
going on how people are being affected
there is a deep political crisis in this
country a vacuum at the executive level
there is no precedent now this has
happened in the past but this time
around there's also no functioning
government and this time around the
parliament is an electoral body it
cannot legislate and this time around
the economy has all but collapsed and
this is why the MPS decided to do this
protest action they are hoping that
other MPS will join them in order to
elect a president but politics Works in
a much different way in this country
since the end of the Civil War the
traditional parties who have been
running this country they choose to hold
dialogue outside State institutions to
try to reach a deal now what are these
MPS telling us they're telling us
there's an urgent need for an executive
Authority in order to deal with this
economic collapse to pass reforms to
deal with a currency which continues to
devaluate every every single day people
are losing purchasing power Public
Schools cannot open because teachers
cannot be paid so the state is
collapsing now we're unable to enter the
legislature to meet these MPS in person
because the governing Alliance are not
permitting journalists inside but we did
manage to speak to them over Skype
two members of parliament from the
so-called forces of change block have
been camped inside lebanon's Parliament
building for two weeks pressing for the
election of a president like much of the
population they're in darkness long
power outages are one of many crises
facing the collapsing country third
demand for open sessions to elect the
president has the support from other MPS
but not from the governing Alliance
which also refuses to allow journalists
into the legislature these politicians
realize this protest May drag on for
weeks but say they are doing their duty
to protect democracy and the rule of law
they are like a member of a club and
they want one thing how to share the
power between them among them this is
the idea they are not apply the
Constitution
no political Alliance has a two-thirds
majority needed to elect a candidate in
the first round of voting the opposition
is divided as is the Hezbollah LED
governing Coalition and it's accused of
preventing open sessions inside
Parliament which would require fewer
votes to choose a head of state
Hezbollah wants to make sure that the
next president elected will ensure the
Riots of Hezbollah to maintain its
weapon the other stumbling issue that
chose choosing a president and choosing
a prime minister and the nature of the
government to be after electing
president need to come in one package
it's how politics has been conducted for
decades these MPS are hoping to change
that but concede they are up against an
establishment that has sidelined State
institutions
we as 12 MPS change MPS are really keen
on really respecting the Constitution
and in reinstating the the the the
public institutions the political
paralysis isn't new the election of the
previous head of state michaloun
followed more than two years of
bargaining that finally ended with a
power sharing deal
the balance of power is in the favor of
the establishment and many fear even if
a president that is elected and a new
government is formed it will be the same
political class blamed for the economic
crisis the same political class who's
done nothing really in the past four
years to stop the financial meltdown
Xena thank you very much indeed that Zen
okota talking to us from Beirut